hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful attacking game uh from this
year's european team championship it's a
alexa sheriff also known as the modern
day tal versus the hungarian grand
master uh viktor erdos and it's uh well
it's a beautiful attacking game like i
said you guys will enjoy it features
many incredible moves and it features a
moment where uh you know i had the game
uh took a different turn you know things
would have been completely different but
it didn't and this is the uh the end
result so let's check it out uh you guys
uh well this will definitely improve
your day and if you figure out the pause
the video moment this will improve your
day at least tenfold so that being said
let's uh check it out so [ __ ] of with
the white pieces opens with e4 that we
have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so uh just uh normal roy
lopez uh we have a6 morphe's defense
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 we
have castles and bishop to e7 uh very
very standard stuff rook to e1 and b5
chasing away the lights visual bishop b3
we have d6
and now c3 preparing to strike in the
center with the d4 we have castles and
now h3 so there are many many games in
the database with this exact same
position uh any move pretty much can be
played here for black black goes for
rook to e8 uh frees up the f8 square for
the bishop and uh sheriff strikes in the
center with d4 we have bishop to b7
getting the bishop to this long diagonal
and now knight to g5 sort of
asking black is he sure of himself of
what he's doing because the f7 pawn is
not weak
and how do you defend this well probably
he's checking if black is feeling
adventurous and wants to play maybe
something like d5
but black says no not really i'm just
gonna bring the rook back rook to f8 and
uh well uh next move maybe i can kick
away the knight with h6 but shirov just
goes back knight to f3 and now black
repeats rook to e8 saying okay you have
the white pieces if you want to repeat i
will very gladly you know accept the
draw by threefold repetition
uh shiro of course not interested in
that he plays a3
and now we have h6 not allowing any more
knight to g5 ideas uh and now there are
some games where bishop the c2 was
played also knight beat to d2 is unknown
move but should have just placed bishop
to a2 and it is now only as of move 14
that we have a completely new game uh so
let's see uh what happens we have bishop
to f8 the standard idea freeing up the e
file for the for the black rook uh and
now d5 grabbing more space in the center
attacking this knight we have knight
back to b8
and now c4 uh grabbing more control in
the center we have c6 challenging white
center and knight to c3 and now we will
see some traits uh we have b captures on
c4 d captures on c6 and bishop captures
on c6 followed by bishop captures on c4
so nothing uh you know unusual here
queen to c7 now as the bishop on c4 is
undefended you probably want to move
this bishop but not if you are alexei
shiro he just plays knight to h4 he says
there is nothing to worry about here
there is no good discovery here that the
bishop can make for the queen to you
know make some threats here uh so just
bishop back to d7 now attacking this
bishop and again you might think the
bishop will now move maybe to b3 to a2
maybe the queen will defend the bishop
with queen to d3 but not when alexa
shiro is playing he just plays knight to
d5 and this is uh well this is uh
basically the chest equivalent of
spitting in someone's face you just
say okay take my bishop and uh not
taking the bishop also uh doesn't uh you
know
release
the tension all that much because if you
don't accept the sacrifice let's say you
just captured the knight here just
bishop captures here attacks the attacks
the rook and for example knight the c6
would defend even bishop captures an h6
is an idea so white has many many
attacking ideas
we're going to capture here rook to c1
put more pressure on the knight here
we're playing rook c3 rook the g3 put
more pressure here queen the queen can
come to d to queen can come directly
into the attack so it's not going to be
easy for black to survive this uh so
black uh boldly accepts the challenge he
plays queen captures on c4 so it's just
a straight out piece sacrifice and now
knight captures uh on f6 with check so
now we have to capture uh otherwise
we're gonna you know yeah we just given
up uh a material for nothing so g
captures on f6 and the now queen to h5
so really uh just going all out
everything is uh going uh into the
attack and this is the one moment uh in
the game where black really could have
uh played a move that uh uh
just equalizes on the spot and it's not
an easy move to find i will ask you to
pause the video here and try to find the
absolute best sequence of moves uh for
for black
while i give you a couple of seconds you
know and try to survive this onslaught
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's king to h7 uh
king to h7 seems like uh
like a silly move but uh you know it's
kind of required it seems like you are
guarding this pawn here uh but you are
really not and here we're just gonna
play bishop captures on h6 and after
bishop captures an h6 we can play rook a
to c1 and now this is the idea uh of
course we want the queen to move so we
can pick up the f7 pawn and the queen
wants to
keep an eye on the f7 pawn the problem
is if you play queen to e6 then knight
to f5 the bishop no longer guards the f5
square and now white is just winning so
we have to play queen to a2
and now after
uh of course rook day one we're gonna
have a nice repetition here and the game
probably ends in a draw uh but there is
another thing after king to h7 although
this is a disgusting engine line so i'm
not gonna even ask you to even consider
it there is this uh idea of playing b3
first now this um
is similar to what uh we've just
discussed but also much different so now
the queen is attacked and the question
is what do you do with the queen uh it's
not it's not the same as going for
bishop captures an h6 right away so now
the thing is if the queen captures on b3
we're gonna capture on h6 and now after
bishop captures uh on h6 now we can play
rook eat the b1 attack the the queen
here so we still want to kick the queen
away from the defense of the f7 square
and now it's uh
not possible to do that because if we
play some like king queen to c4 then
rook to b4 and now white is winning of
course you don't have any of the squares
available and of course queen to e6 just
loses the knight to
f5 so what you would have to do here is
play queen captures on b1 and after rook
captures play something like rook the g8
so now this is the the position that uh
could arise uh but it's still of course
completely uh winning for white so
congratulations on fighting king to h7
uh but with uh the inclusion of this
incredible b3 move it still doesn't work
but it shows how resilient you are when
you have to really you know figure
things out so uh this is uh
the skinned h7 very impressive but also
if b3 is found then even that is
insufficient in the game f5 was played
but this uh also does uh doesn't make it
all that difficult for uh for sure we
have bishop captures an h6 bishop
captures and now queen captures an h6
and now
we have f4 so now you don't have to
worry about rook to e3 rook to g3 but
here comes knight to f5 shirov is
threatening checkmate with queen to g7
so we have to eliminate the knight
bishop captures on f5 we have e captures
on f5 and now again the threat of f6 and
queen to g7 checkmate
is uh too great to not play f6 here so
we have to play f6 block the pawn here
and now prepare to bring the queen back
to f7 if needed so queen g6 check king
to f8 and now queen captures an f6 with
check and finally we bring our queen
back to defense uh to help out with the
defense so queen to f7 queen captures on
d6 grabbing some more pawns queen to e7
now and now uh you'd expect white to
keep the queens on the board you know
just move the queen maybe with check
maybe harder somewhere maybe try to push
some pawns before activating the rooks
but here just rook eight to d1 sure says
i'm up three pawns this is enough for me
i don't need the queens on the board
anymore i can attack without a queen
so queen captures on d6 was played rook
captures on d6 and now rook to a7 and
here we have this end game where black
is up a knight but white is up three
pawns so white starts pushing g4 and now
we have three connected pass pawns now
that's uh definitely worth one piece and
even if you capture it doesn't matter
white has doubled f pawns so you know
undoubling is uh even better for white
so after g4 we have rook to h7
activating the rook with tempo the h3
pawn is attacked king the g2 defending
and now knight to d7 trying to give up
the a6 pawn for some uh activity knight
to c5 maybe followed by knights to d3
and then well you have to activate this
knight because that's the only thing you
have for those three uh past pawns so
here just b4 sure knows the importance
of this move and well he just pushes it
now takes away the c5 square from the
knight and you don't really have all
that many good moves here uh so uh it's
maybe best to be active with e4 but in
the game rook the c8 was played trying
to get some activity across the c file
but now rook e to d1 attacking the
knight here rook to c7 and now just the
g5 so the knight really doesn't have all
that many squares you're gonna
start pushing these pawns maybe the king
can even join the attack and it's not
easy surviving this with black e4 is
played but now g6 attacking the rook
rook the g7 now h4 you know that h5 h6
is coming
and here we have knight to e5 uh if you
just continue with rook to e7 f6 is just
too strong you're going to have to give
up the knight and uh well after check
let's take into g7 recaptures on f4
there's no compensation here white is
just uh
white is just completely winning so
after this h4 move we have knight to e5
instead trying to well create uh some uh
something in the position trying to
complicate but just h5 this is
sufficient h6 is coming so knight to d3
disconnecting the white rooks uh but
still just h6 we have rook g to d7
uh now attacking the rook here but we
can simply trade captures captures and
h7 now we're threatening h8 and bringing
a queen into the game king to g7 and now
of course f6 deflecting the king from
the defense of the h8 square so we have
to go back we can't capture the pawn and
now the simplest way to conclude matters
uh rook to h1 we guard the h7 pawn one
more time and now the threat of g7 is
just too great f3 check was played but
after king to g3 it was in this position
on mu 46 that victor erdog resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so an impressive impressive game by
by sure of you know just uh the the one
opportunity he got for for attack
you know he he was just unstoppable and
here you resign there's no defense from
g7 whatever you play e3 we're gonna play
g7 check and now you have to you know
give up some material will bring a queen
into the game with check
and that's it there's no more hope here
so really incredible that after this uh
bishop the d7 move you know just trying
to ask what is the bishop doing of
course you're hoping that white will
also waste a move with his bishop uh but
not when you're playing against shiro
just knight to d5 just an incredible
beautiful move uh you know just
unleashing the attack and and
it's a move you can't ignore you cannot
stop this you just have to accept the
piece
and hope for the best and against the
player like shiro that rarely goes well
but yeah once again congratulations to
everyone who found king to h7 that isn't
really working but it's you know a very
resilient way of of going down uh so
congratulations on that as well uh and
yeah i would like to thank uh uh dylan
streeter benjamin echenlor branislav
frank ploy and michael kennedy for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
uh is happening in the chess world the
world championship starts in nine days
so you know we're getting ready for that
and also yes i've received many requests
to show the aliereza game so that game
is probably coming up next uh thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day